Hey, great to be back on CNN.
We have Texas senator author
of Unwoke, Ted Cruz.
Okay.
And former psychology professor
Jordan Peterson,
and opinion columnist
for New York Times, Pamela Paul.
(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
Okay, so... here we go.
This first one is for you.
Do Republicans
have a good answer
to address the border crisis
other than bussing migrants
to liberal cities?
Oh, a little dig there, Ted.
-A little...
-(CHUCKLING)
It's actually very simple,
which is secure the border.
And when you apprehend someone,
send them home.
When Joe Biden started,
we had the lowest rate of
illegal immigration in 45 years.
And he came in, and he
immediately reimposed
catch-and-release,
and it produced the worst rate
of illegal immigration
in our nation's history.
I spend a lot of time
at the border.
I go out on midnight patrol
with border patrol agents.
-The problem--
-Really?
Many times.
You should come.
I'll actually bring you
if you're interested in--
-No, I'm good.
-(LAUGHTER)
-If you want to see--
-I'm good. No, no.
I will tell you this,
actually, Bill,
if you saw what was happening,
you would be horrified,
because the people being
abused by the traffickers--
You don't understand it 'til you
see it firsthand, and it is--
it is immoral what's happening
at our southern border.
-I take your word.
-Okay.
I don't have to go.
(LAUGHTER)
-But it is easy to fix...
-Okay, but--
...because what actually worked
is we had an agreement
with Mexico that was called
the Remain in Mexico agreement,
which says that if someone
crossed into Mexico illegally,
from typically Central
or South America,
they would remain in Mexico
while their asylum case
was proceeding in the US.
And the numbers plummeted.
We had the lowest rate,
as I said, in 45 years.
And then Biden came in
and ripped that international
agreement to shreds.
-And that's what produced now
8.4 million illegal aliens...
-Okay. Okay.
...since Biden's been president.
Boy, I walked right into
that one, didn't I?
-TED CRUZ: You asked.
-BILL MAHER: I know--
I know you know this,
this is part of your...
But, all right, let me ask it
a different way.
Do you think if we attacked
it from the reverse angle,
-in other words, if we punish
the employers, it would--
-Absolutely.
And you think we should?
Oh, look, I am all for E-Verify.
I would absolutely
punish the employers.
And I've introduced legislation
to do that multiple times.
And what happened?
Your party must not like that,
because we know
cheap labor is good.
So look, there are a lot of
Republicans who don't like that.
There are fewer,
but I do think that the
Republican Party is changing.
I think we're becoming much more
of a blue-collar party,
which I think
is a very good thing.
-Okay. This is for... (LAUGHS)
-(LAUGHTER)
They are switching,
aren't they?
Yes, it's interesting that the
parties are kind of switching,
like, who the elitists are.
It used to be
the country club Republicans,
and now it's the
Chardonnay-sipping Democrat.
-Yeah.
-PAMELA PAUL: Yeah. Yeah.
I know you've written about it.
It's an interesting do-si-do
the parties do.
It's almost happened completely
in Canada now.
The Conservatives are basically
the working class party
in Canada.
-MAHER: Right.
-Yeah.
But the heart of
the Republican Party
are truck drivers
and steel workers
and cops and firefighters.
And I think that
is a fantastic shift.
I think we should be
the party of jobs,
-we should be the party of--
-Okay.
...of people
who want to work hard.
Okay, okay.
(LAUGHTER)
For Jordan,
are men more susceptible
to loneliness than women?
No.
-No, well-- well--
-MAHER: Okay.
We know this.
So, at puberty, women
become more sensitive
to negative emotion than men.
And then, that's permanent,
on average,
through the entire life course.
And it looks like
it's associated
with hormonal changes.
And so, cross-culturally,
women experience higher levels
of depression and anxiety
and shame and guilt,
all the negative emotions
that clump together.
And so, loneliness
is a pain-related emotion,
and women are more
susceptible to that.
What do you-- Now we--
Everybody recognizes that women,
girls, mature faster than boys.
I mean,
this is why they're going
out with the upper classmen.
And at any age, they usually
don't want somebody
exactly their age,
even though this country is like
crazy for age appropriate--
God forbid, we go out of that.
(LAUGHTER)
But, what do you think,
if you had to name a number,
of like how far ahead
the women are years-wise.
Well, we know women prefer
men four years older
cross-culturally.
-MAHER: Four.
-Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
-But--
-And it's not necessarily only
a matter of maturation.
It's also the case that women
are more attracted by--
by socio-economic status
and productivity
than men are in
relationship with women.
How many years head-start
does a man need
to match his maturity level
to a woman's level?
I think 40.
(LAUGHTER)
JORDAN PETERSON:
Well, there's wide--
wide individual differences
in that too, Bill.
PAUL: I'm learning a lot
about women here.
MAHER: Am I wrong about that?
(CHUCKLING)
-Well I-- I'm-- Yeah.
-MAHER: Okay.
I would say I have a different
view of women from Jordan.
But, what do you mean different?
Well, I mean,
the depression, anxiety--
What else do we have that's...?
-PETERSON: Negative--
-Loneliness.
-PETERSON: Negative emotions.
-Everything negative--
PETERSON: No, no, no.
No, not everything negative.
-Okay.
-Just because men are much more
likely to be aggressive,
and to end up in prison,
and to be alcoholic,
and they're overrepresented
in learning disabilities.
Like, there there are sex
differences in psychopathology,
and they're not all tilted
negatively towards women.
Definitely not.
So, but negative emotion,
it's absolutely clear
that that's the case.
And it's-- The biggest
differences are in the countries
that have the most
gender-equal economies
and socio-economic structures.
So, the differences
between men and women
in terms of sensitivity
to negative emotion
maximize in Scandinavia.
MAHER: Wow, so...
Scandinavians are also much
happier than we are, though.
Yeah, well, comparatively, their
women are less happy, so...
-MAHER: I mean...
-(LAUGHTER)
I know.
I've seen those surveys too.
I find it a very difficult
thing, to quantify happiness.
Or, it's kind of like
that pain chart in the hospital.
One to 10, like somebody's three
is somebody else's eight.
You know what I mean?
How happy are they really
in Scandinavia? I don't know.
-Well, happiness--
-I know this is the greatest
country in the world,
right, Ted?
-Amen. Hallelujah.
-(LAUGHTER)
(LAUGHTER)
All right, how--
I'm not gonna get
that one wrong.
I-- (LAUGHS)
How will Joe Manchin's
decision--
ah, this happened today,
Joe Manchin,
West Virginia senator--
...decision not
to seek re-election
impact the balance of power
in the Senate?
I saw a lot
of gleeful Democrats.
We got rid of Joe Manchin.
Good luck trying to elect
another Democrat
in West Virginia.
John Fetterman will win
Dancing with the Stars before--
Yeah, I mean, he succeeded
Robert Byrd, and that's--
But, I guess he's making noise
about a third party run.
I think that he is one of
the several Democrats now
who have decided that something
has to be done, you know,
to offer
an alternative to Biden.
I mean, unfortunately,
Jill Stein
has also jumped into the race,
and that worked out
really well last time.
So, but I think that the
balance of power in the Senate
is the bigger threat.
MAHER: What do you think
about Joe Manchin?
You must have worked with him--
Well, look,
I like Joe personally.
He's a very affable guy.
But he's so much
more conservative
than most Democrats,
so is there a place--
His not running means
Republicans will win that seat.
And in fact,
I would be willing to bet
-the Democrats won't even--
-No, but could you vote
for a guy like Joe Manchin?
-No.
-Never? Really?
He's not conservative
enough for you?
Because I served with him,
and actually,
he votes on 90 percent
of the times
for things that are terrible.
-So, for example, I watched
the panel discussion you had.
-(LAUGHTER)
You were talking
about Iran and Hamas,
and I said
at the end of our interview
that I thought Biden had direct
responsibility for this attack,
and you said why.
Let me give you one reason why.
Joe Biden is responsible
for 100 billion dollars
going to the Ayatollah.
-He made a decision
to do that...
-Okay.
...and Iran funds Hamas.
-The Wall Street Journal
reported in September...
-Uh-huh, right, yes. Okay.
...they brought Hamas terrorists
to Iran and trained them in Iran
to carry out the attack.
And I start from
a really simple principle,
don't give money to terrorists
who want to kill us.
-Okay. Right.
-And that, unfortunately,
the Democrat Party
is on the other side of that.
It's--
You went to Harvard,
as you point out often.
-(LAUGHTER)
-You know-- You know--
-You know--
-Listen-- Listen, Cornell man.
You're not exactly
a man of the people.
Right.
I try not to mention it, though.
But you know it's more
complicated than that.
-No, I actually
don't think it is.
-Okay.
When the Ayatollah
chants "death to America"
-and "death to Israel..."
-MAHER: Yes.
-I believe him.
-MAHER: Right.
MAHER: But what the complicated
part is what I was saying,
the people of Iran
is different than the regime.
But he didn't give the money
to the people.
-MAHER: I--
He gave the money
to the Ayatollah.
-I...
-The person he's giving it to
is the one who has pledged
he wants to murder as many Jews
and as many Americans
as possible.
And giving him-- Obama
gave him 100 billion dollars,
Biden gave him
100 billion dollars,
and that was
catastrophically foolish.
All right, I'm against that.
-All right, you created an app--
-See, we've got an agreement.
No, I mean,
I'm against killing Americans.
(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE)
For--
And I don't care who knows it.
All right.
In less than one minute,
because we're on CNN,
Jordan, you created an app that
teaches people how to write.
Is that an effective way
to teach them
to be critical thinkers?
-Yes.
-MAHER: Yes.
The most-- The most profound
way of learning to think
-is to learn to write,
and edit, in particular.
-MAHER: Yes. I--
Because that's how you get
rid of the stupid ideas.
-MAHER: I agree.
-To answer your--
There's-- There's three areas.
There's thinking.
And then there's talking.
And then there's writing it.
Each one makes you better.
-Writing, you really do edit.
-PETERSON: Yeah.
Talking is a--
is better than just what's just
-going on in your mind.
-PETERSON: Yeah.
MAHER: That's where people get--
PETERSON: Other people
edit when you're talking.
-Edit you. Yeah.
-Yes.
And you don't--
obviously, lots of people
say lots of stupid things,
but at least you have
some mechanism.
But what goes on in your mind.
I mean, this is the problem
when people say, you know,
"God talked to me."
He didn't. You talked to him.
He didn't answer.
Those are called thoughts.
(LAUGHTER)
Anyway, thank you, CNN.
Great to be back.
Thank you, Pamela.
We'll see you next week.